optimal at this altitude I can run flat
out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking and I also do personal
questions now soon I'm a cybernetic
organism living tissue over metal
endoskeleton this episode is brought to
you by 99 designs 99 designs is a great
partner for creating and growing your
business it's a one-stop shop for all of
your graphic design needs whether that's
a logo website business card or anything
else I use 99 designs to get book cover
prototypes for the 4-hour body which
went on to become a number one New York
Times bestseller I also use them for
banner ads illustrations and other
things with 99designs designers around
the world to compete to create the best
design for you you give feedback and
then pick your favorite you end up happy
or you get your money back it's very
simple you can check out a few of my own
designs and those of yours meaning Tim
Ferriss show listeners at 99 designs com
forward slash Tim and right now my
listeners you guys will get a free $99
upgrade on your first design that's 99
designs com a forward slash Tim check it
out this episode is brought to you by
wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront is a massively disruptive in
a good way
set it and forget it investing service
led by technologists from places like
Apple and world-famous investors it has
exploded in popularity in the last two
years and they now have more than two
and a half billion dollars under
management in fact some of my very good
friends investors in Silicon Valley have
millions of their own money in
wealthfront so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free
exactly the portfolio they put you in
and if you just want to take their
advice run with
do it yourself you can do that or as I
would you can set it and forget it and
here's why
the value of wealthfront is in the
automation of habits and strategies that
investors should be using on a regular
basis but normally aren't great
investing is a marathon not a sprint and
little things that you may or may not be
familiar with like automatic tax loss
harvesting rebalancing your portfolio
across more than 10 asset classes and
dividend reinvestment add up to very
large amounts of money over longer
periods of time wealthfront
as I mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15,000 which is managed for
free if you use my link wealthfront comm
forward slash Tim that is less than five
dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor on the
show it's because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get fifteen thousand
dollars managed for free if you decide
to open an account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest for you take two minutes fill
out their questionnaire at wealthfront
dot-com forward slash Tim it's fast it's
free there's no downside that I can
think of
hello my savvy sexy friends this is tim
ferriss and welcome to another episode
of the tim ferriss show where it is my
job to deconstruct world-class
performers from all different walks of
life industries areas of speciality to
tease out the routines habits tools that
you can use this episode we have
Christopher summer and this is his
second appearance but this is a
standalone episode he is the former US
National Team gymnastics coach his last
episode was one of the most popular that
has ever been on the podcast he's also
the founder of gymnastic bodies which is
a training system
I'm currently testing been using it for
a few months now I have no affiliation
with it I don't get any kickbacks as a
world renowned Olympic coach coach
summer is known for bullying his
students into some of the strongest most
powerful athletes in the world we
covered a lot the last time around and
this episode has many many answers to a
lot of your most common questions for
instance what home equipment should
someone invest in first for $100 or less
what are his thoughts on weighted
stretches if there's a place for them in
gymnastic strength training GST what are
the best examples of how to use them
sample exercises what does lower body
GST look like for a 40 year old former
athlete for instance we talked about or
he brings up the best distinction
between mobility and flexibility that
I've ever heard exercise progressions
for bar muscle-ups what might those look
like or the very least tests that you
can use to determine if it's even safe
for you to attempt training for such a
thing foam rolling or mobility tools
what does he think and do you change
gymnastic strength training or how do
you change it for tall people say over
six feet tall or for women so there you
have it and if you would like to test
out gymnastic bodies I again have no
type of affiliation whatsoever but coach
will be putting up some sample videos
that feature exercises mentioned in this
episode and others on gymnastic bodies
calm forward-slash Tim it's also a sales
page there are a couple of
different discounts and whatnot for you
guys if you want to try it out but they
should be adding and probably have
already added videos at the very bottom
or somewhere on that page for you to
check out and if for whatever reason
they are not there you can go to youtube
and look for gymnastic bodies and find
all sorts of good stuff so without
further ado please enjoy my second
public conversation we have had dozens
second public conversation with Coach
Summer coach welcome back to the show
Thank You Tim it is very nice to be on
the phone yet again and I thought we
would start with what we were talking
about very briefly before we hit record
and I said you know what people might
find this of interest so is context for
folks I've been doing some rings work
gymnastic rings work and with some
assistance of equipment that you helped
to put together and set up which
includes the 50 50 some people call a
variation of the dream machine which
basically is a harness that allows you
to decrease the weight you're supporting
on your hands and then power levers
which look like robocop gauntlets and
you can attach the Rings on top of your
forearm in different places with many
different holes running from the wrist
to closer to the elbow so that you can
shorten the fulcrum I guess to improve
your physics so that in this way you
have progressive resistance with the
Rings which is otherwise very difficult
to achieve so it's very very cool and I
did something stupid while playing
around or not playing around actually I
was taking very seriously Iron Cross
work and hurt my right wrist and it's I
thought it was broken I had MRIs it
appears to be a ligament strain but here
we are three weeks later and I can't
hold a push-up without decent pain on
the back of the right wrist so it's
asking you what I might do at this point
to speed recovery and I would love to
restart your answer and go from there
okay all right good deal
now before we go into the healing part
let's let's review how the accident
happens so that all the listeners don't
think I'm an who destroyed you
oh right yeah exactly and and and also
one thing that coach asked me before we
got started
is he goes I thought you were smart and
I see mine took two which I answered the
older I get the less sure of that I
become the I was subconsciously
compensating I think to cheat a little
bit in this movement so so with the
power lovers you don't need to use a
false grip and you have metal very close
to the top of your wrist and as I was
doing these East Centrex while I was
doing positive but also lowering into an
Iron Cross and then doing statics I
started rolling my hand into a false
grip unnecessarily where you're
basically supporting the Rings across
your palm and wrist as opposed to solely
in your palm and that drove the top of
my wrist into the metal to such an
extent that I sprained or and and in
other words kept driving it in yeah well
this is this is where I'm in Rosina
exercise after exercise yeah so then I
continued with Maltese and
Vic's work because I was in Paris and it
took me like three weeks to find a place
where I could set up all this equipment
so I was like god dammit
I'm gonna get this workout done I
literally coach you'd be proud of this
part you'd be ashamed of how stupid I
behaved otherwise but I took a separate
suitcase with me overseas just full of
equipment for training and so we did it
so I finally I get in uber and managed
to get to the one gym in Paris that
might let me set this stuff up and then
literally in the first two sets act like
an idiot and Hurst my wrist I was just
like absolutely no way I am
finishing this workout so there you have
it
but so yes I take full take full blame
for that one what should I do
alright so
tim and i were talking just before we
started record and that this is a
connective tissue injury where the
ligaments and that on the top of the
wrist got mashed got compressed up into
the metal you know over and over and
over so they're basically they're
they're really really bruised and
because the connective tissue heals so
slowly remember from first podcast that
connective tissues metabolic rate is one
tenth that of muscle tissue so basically
once it's hurt you know there's there's
no way to get off the train you have to
ride this to the end and it's going to
be a while now what we can do to kind of
finesse this though is understanding
that metabolic rate ice then for
connective tissue work you know we use
ice initially to help reduce
inflammation but then after that it will
actually slow the metabolic rate because
it doesn't have its own capillary system
it gets its blood through diffusion so
what we'll do instead is use heat I
first came across this Wow
early 2000s we had an athlete who had
severs usually happens when athletes
when they're growing their varied the
strong athletes especially when they hit
a growth spurt severs is irritation of
the Achilles where it goes down into the
heel so when they're tumbling they're
running they're sprinting you know that
heel gets painful and he'd been growing
for a while so on and off for the better
part of a year we had tried ice with no
results no results at all in desperation
if you will trying to find other answers
which is usually how good answers are
found when the everyday stuff isn't
working
came across an ultra marathon excite and
against all Convention they said use
heat they had had wonderful
responses with it so ours was super
simple when it got a hot cold pack throw
it in some boiling water takes a little
practice figuring out you know how long
to leave it in think we were two minutes
perhaps you want it just warm enough
that it's right on the edge of being too
hot for comfort
and then just leave it on and let it
cool naturally I in a week we had better
results from that heat a couple of times
a day than we did from a year of ice and
at what point would you make the switch
so if someone let's just say an
anonymous idiot who goes to Paris and
mashes their wrists into metal
repeatedly is it is it two weeks later
three weeks later or how do you how do
you course map the symptoms 24 hours 24
hours to control inflammation for as far
as ice is concerned and then I jump into
heat got it okay so it's a it's a it's a
quick it's a quick jump in and did you
with this particular athlete did you use
any type of contrast therapy going from
that hot to cold hot to cold or did you
keep it to the hunt at that time we'd
never used any hot water we use the hot
packs right and so we would just lay
them on top now I think it was at that
time we weren't combining but it could
be very interesting that the issue that
you run into if you do contrast baths
with a wrist is that you have to soak
the whole hand right and then it's not
like an ankle to the hands of course
you're pulling out the oil your hands
now it's tough to get any work done
where with an ankle going back and forth
no big deal for those listening a
contrast bath is simply alternating
between room-temperature water and then
ice water two separate buckets set a
timer go for a minute in the ice and
then I just set your phone to beep in a
minute and we'll have athletes do is
just you know throw a movie in the
protocol is keep alternating buckets
back and forth as long as you can stand
it without losing your mind and why use
room-temperature water as opposed to hot
water excellent well what happens is
it's I first stumbled across this I
don't remember the name of the trainer
but it was the guy who was working with
Michael Jordan back in his heyday and
Michael had had a
game one evening rolled his ankle and
had a game the next night so as an oh
moment so you know Michael like
anybody who's a high level performer is
dedicated he's obsessed with doing his
best so that evening he did the contrast
bath protocol for two hours you know be
switch would switch next night on an
injured ankle scored 40 points well yeah
the nice the nice thing with the
contrast bath is the cold is there long
enough to reduce inflammation but then
it goes back into the room temperature
and it's not been cold long enough to
reduce circulation by an extreme extent
so you kind of get the best of both
worlds now is there is there any reason
to keep the warmer water at room
temperature versus hot water the
difference going back and forth between
we've never used more than room
temperature it could be significantly
uncomfortable because the ice water is
ice water right you know we make that so
we we just want to bring it up enough we
don't want to make it hot no we're not
trying to make soup but just just enough
to get a little blood flow back into the
cold again got it all right I will go
get some reusable heat packs or ice cold
packs looking at home equipment this is
something that came up quite a bit after
our first chat what home equipment
should someone invest in first and you
kind of look at it darnit
yeah to get started if anything like
let's look at the on the inexpensive
side like hundred dollars or less and
then if you have unlimited budget okay
actually you know super simple and I
designed it this way on purpose
because you've got to test the water you
got to find out is it my thing you know
do do I enjoy it not it's not it's not
always just a matter of is it effective
does it work obviously it's effective
obviously it works but then it becomes a
matter of you know is this my flavor of
ice cream that I like you know so
basically they need some floor space
they need a bar you know they need an
overhead bar
maybe some light dumbbells a dowel a
dowel will be a long straight stick and
other than that they're kind of pretty
much good to go I mean we really went
out of our way to make it as as simple
to get started as possible what would
someone use a dowel for and I mean I
have a few in mind but for people who
aren't familiar so this is effectively a
broom stick or even perhaps a PVC pipe
yeah broom handle a long wooden dowel we
used that for different shoulder
mobility so when we when we trained
adults so this kind of goes back to the
general structure of development is
before we can get into the really cool
stuff light hair on fire get all strong
yada yada yada we first have to undo
years of damage from dusk Patrol and
that means mobility is jacked up so
we're going to use the broom sticks the
dowels with a little bit of weight on
them to start rebuilding that shoulder
girdle mobility got it and so that for
those people interested I mean this is
it in that category we would have
various types of dislocates right it's
okay it's some flexion work where
they're working on lifting their arms
overhead
probably for adults their greatest
deficit especially those who have been
having any type of a professional career
you know that involves paperwork is
they're going to have extremely poor
shoulder extension to describe shoulder
extensions standing upright hands at my
side lifting my arms back behind me yeah
I would put myself in that category for
sure and the the shoulder extension I
mean I've seen some improvements now
granted I've gone from absolutely
disgusting to watch to just moderately
offensive to watch but but still a large
improvement you would actually be very
impressed with my progress that I've
made prior to the wrist injury that is
on one thing which is if if people look
up dislocates and they use a normal
Grips so let's just say people are
starting with a dowel in front of them
they're holding it like a barbell in a
deadlift with their arms slightly wider
so it's overhand grip the the opposite
of that in some ways would be the dorsal
grip right where you start with the bar
behind you and you're holding it as if
you're going to try to do a bicep curl
through your legs right so your palms
are facing forward so you might recall
when I tried to get my arms I couldn't
get up at all but then when we started
at the top my wrists were so inflexible
that I couldn't bring the bar down at
all so I made a lot of progress on
dorsal so it's it's really illuminating
to me to look at not only the shoulder
restriction that I have but how it is
affected by shifts in the grip right
because yes this is this this might be
one reason why people are like I've got
great shoulder extension and they're
using regular dislocates let's just say
to assess that and then they go on the
Rings and they're not prepared for it
and they're going through all these
different types of hand positions and
arm positions and boom they tear
something and they're out of commission
the dowel you could also use dowels I
remember if you could for hollow body
rocks or arch body rocks crash for sure
that's something why is that helpful and
so for people listening the hollow body
position would be uh well one way to
think of it would be almost like a a
diver in the Olympics when they're
jumping on the diving board before
taking off so they're not arched they
have sort of a slightly concave if you
were to lay on your stomach put your
hands out in front of you put your toes
on the ground inland lift your body off
of the ground a few inches is that a
fair assessment sort of that would be
that would be the arch if they were
laying on their stomach they did the
opposite laying on their back that would
be the hollow oh right right right so
just what would I'm just trying to
explain is the hollow body position
right so the if you're on your back
you're sort of rolling on the pelvis
with good posterior pelvic tilt right
just everything tucked under think think
of the body as a long flattened C letter
C yep and what what does holding the
dowel achieve with with the hollow body
rock in that case or the opposite where
you're on your stomach and kind of doing
a again that flattened C but what is the
dowel accomplish give them something
visceral to feel so with as far as
shoulder girdle is concerned if they
shrug their ears their shoulders up to
their ears that would be scapular
extension we do the opposite that would
be depression so when they have that
holding it with just a regular grip and
push that dowel up above their head that
let helps them physically to activate
the shoulder girdle and get that
extension through their shoulders hmm
and for people who have tried either of
these and I encourage people to try them
try it with and without a dowel and it's
and video yourself if you can because
it's incredible how having something to
hold on to can address a lot of the
problems that you have at least in my
experience that was true with the arch
body rock in particular and what what
other pieces of equipment if any for
getting started that's that's a pretty
solid list because a lot of their stuff
we're not even though I know they would
like to right they can't jump right in
there yet they're going to have to pay
their dues we're going to take six
months maybe eight months re we're going
to do some strength work but primarily
we're going to address those joint
deficits those mobility deficits because
if you can't get in the correct position
how can you exercise in the correct
position mm-hmm you you can't it's it's
I I was speaking with someone the other
day and we're kind of pointing out some
of the fallacies in in traditional
training where it's just kind of
accepted that as you get older your body
can no longer tolerate doing overhead
weighted work now you can't you can't do
I'm a strong guy I can't do military
press anymore and rather than them
trying to
find out what the cause of that deficit
is they just kind of accept it oh yeah
my shoulders are I just can't
lift my arms over my head anymore and
I'm I'm the exact I'll says it seriously
you find it acceptable that you can't
raise your arms over your head anymore
me what what if there's something on a
shelf I mean not now we're not doing
world-class performance how about we
want to be in your closet and you just
want to get a suitcase down and no shed
I just can't you know I'm just gonna
live in a life where my arms don't go
above my shoulder forever and to me
that's just asinine
we're not trying to be contortionists or
anything we're just you know this is
your natural range of motion and you're
going to sacrifice this for the rest of
your life rather than okay well what
caused this well what caused it was a
steady diet and nothing wrong with these
exercises they just did them to
exclusion a steady diet of benchpress
and curls which is going to make the
pecs really tight it's going to make the
bicep really tight now there's nothing
at all wrong with bench there's nothing
at all wrong with curl but it has to be
done in a way with a balanced program
that maintains that healthy range of
motion in the joint we don't just get
tighter and tighter and tighter whether
they just going to eventually lay there
and not move you know be there sometimes
some people a nice thing to do
especially for for the listeners here
they'll get a big kick out of this first
time I saw this blew my mind go to
youtube and enter it in the search enter
high speed karate chop high speed karate
chop yeah I know so cool such that such
a corny thing to say what they'll see is
going to blow their mind first thing
they're going to do is going to be a
regular speed black belt is going to be
there and he is going to break a cement
block with his hand I've done it I'm
sure a ton of listeners out there have
done it no big deal right
bringing us a bit block with their hands
yeah yeah I mean it's not it's not like
you get you get attacked I mean you'll
see it and for those of us who didn't
say yeah yeah that's what it was dah dah
dah there's training for it but then
what they're going to show is they're
going to show what happens to the
physical structure at
four thousand frames a second it's
astounding what happens it's astounding
and it's also important to remember that
this happens in all athletic activities
what we think happens when we're
training is that our bones are getting
denser and firmer and stronger well what
this video is going to show that as his
hand comes down on that block and he's
trying to break it that you'll see the
bones almost liquid folding over
themselves going through all yeah the
first time I saw I was completely
freaked I was like what in the hell is
this he's crippled himself he it's over
it's done he is whole hand is snapped
and then you see the bones come back
this then when you see it it's important
it's always important to try to look for
the core principle of what's going on
what this is illustrating as our eyes
aren't fast enough to see it but this is
the essential nature of what our
skeletal system does it's not to be
strong and stiff and brittle it's to
absorb force and then rebound back
against it so someone's playing tennis
if it's running back someone jumping any
of this so the bones are designed to be
for plyometric training they're designed
for this they've actually taken some
older adults and will put them on
something as simple and gentle as jump
rope and just that small impact from the
jump rope built more strength than
traditional weightlifting this is why
we'll see older adults when they fall
and they break a hip it's not that it's
that the bone bent and it kept bending
it didn't come back again with just to
underscore something you said earlier
which is a lot of people give up blame
age I'm just my shoulders done
sorry I'm just going to I'm just going
to assume this desk sitting position for
the rest of my life or whatever it is
there's an Instagram account that you
introduced me to which any time I feel
like copping out with some
yes excuse that is repeated by a lot of
people my age I'm 39 right now I look at
I'm not sure I'm pronouncing it
correctly but Matt's trained so people
check this guy astray yeah the zoo s tra
and E correct so 53 year old who's doing
gymnastics strength training guard when
he was 48 yes sir when he's 48 so this
is uh it's a great account currently has
about 2,500 followers so I'll be curious
to see where it does about to get a lot
more about he had to get a lot more but
very inspiring to watch this guy
inspiring and Matt's was in the same
position as a lot of the listeners Matt
started training with us because as dr.
Tolin mats owns a restaurant supply
companies one of the co-owners and it
work in huge hours and the doctor pretty
much told them if you don't start taking
care of yourself you go out and get some
exercise you're not going to be here in
a couple years I mean literally that
point-blank it wasn't well I'm a little
concerned maybe you could do a little
better now the doctor flat-out told them
you're gonna be a dead if you
don't fix it
I like doctors like that I need to find
so much things like that please we we
need more of those uh so let's talk
about just something we'll see a lot in
that Instagram account which is
stretching and specifically I'm not
going to be labor at this point but on
the gear side of things one question I
often ask people is what what have you
changed your mind on in the last few
years and I don't know if this is in the
last few years but could you talk about
stretch straps for a second because
stretch straps straps that appear in the
you have orange demonstrate using the
straps for various yes in the hamstring
series yeah for four years and this was
just me being national team because as a
national team coach your your reality my
reality I'm sure all other national team
coach our reality of what is average of
what is normal become skewed over the
years simply because of the quality of
the athletes and how exceptional they
are that we saw
around ourselves with and we quit
looking at them as exceptional and it
just becomes our normal day-to-day
experience and so we look at other
people then not as regular we start
looking at them as my god they're
seriously up how do they get out
of bed in the morning I don't understand
well we kind of at first brought that
same one to there stretching and so
there's a piece of equipment called a
stretch strap which is basically it's a
long circle of nylon strapping that is
then sewn into kind of mini loops they
just make a daisy chain of it then we
also like to use yoga blocks we use
those to accommodate reduce range of
motion now for years I thought those
were just silly crap I thought you know
take the training wheels off the bike
and go out and ride the damn bike and I
was completely wrong completely wrong
what it does is you can use this
combination of the blocks guts and the
stretch straps to actually someone who's
crazy crazy tight it gives them an
opportunity to actually get some work in
so they can start progressed it down
yeah start progres timey not and that's
the name of the game but what we try
where I've come to now is they don't
need to start exceptional we don't know
how far they're going to go we just had
someone share he's been doing the
stretch courses for a year a really good
student Ryan Bailey he just sent a
testimonial in it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous how much progress he made in
a year of just consistent stretching
he's got full chest two legs on his Pike
now he's got can sit down he can pull
his uh touch his head to his toes his
splits are almost all the way down and
and just he's astounded he can't believe
it he's ecstatic and part of that was we
just started and let them scale the
movement according to where they are
right now cuz in order to make progress
first got except where you are right and
if your starting position because of in
flexibility is postural II unsound right
because you don't have the blocks you
don't have then you're just developing
compensations and problems that will
let's even be more specific we've got
people who can't sit on the floor they
cannot and by that I mean they can't sit
on the floor with their legs in a
straddle and sit up straight like
straight in front of them and together
you have either legs legs straight
together in front of them or legs apart
right on the floor and straight they
can't do it their back their glutes
their hamstrings are so tight that in
order for them to sit on the floor they
have to slouch they have to slouch
rather than opposite right being able to
sit up tall with a flat back instead of
sitting on their sacrum of their
tailbone sit on their glutes and their
hamstring and so one potential way that
you could use the block in that case
would be sitting on one or two yoga
exactly exactly and which I had to do if
people really want to feel ridiculous
uh you can try to do something called I
guess what was I doing it was straddle
Pike pulses I did enjoy those I sent
coach videos of the SU there's a good
chance you'll have a glute medius a
contraction we'll call it that not a
contraction yeah yes a severe cramp that
will lead you to fall over in pain or
those who haven't seen the video Tim is
an excellent dancer as he was rolling
around on the floor uh why do you when
someone's doing say a hurdler stretch
okay so and I'll just assume people know
what that is you can look it up if not
but why do you elevate the heel of the
straight leg on top of a block well it
would depend right because maybe if they
are more advanced enough that they can
be on the floor will elevate because
what that will do is most people will
without realizing
allow the knee to go bent so then where
the hamstring crosses the knee and where
the calf crosses the knee coming up
neither those are being addressed them
but more than likely what will happen
especially when they're starting is
rather than elevate the foot we're going
to live we've we've had people that are
so tight they have to start sitting on a
chair in order to try to get in the
right position that their feet on the
ground out in front of them and they
actually have to elevate and it's it's
not it's what the hard thing form is you
just you know you got to be got to be
understanding of where your body's at
it's not a good thing it's not a bad
thing it's a what it is thing and if
we're expanding to weighted stretches
this is a question that a number of
folks has had what are your thoughts on
weighted stretches if there's a place
for it in its GSD shell okay it's
essential what are some of the best
examples of how to use them for novices
or novices or intermediate yeah maybe
before before an example you know is why
trying why do a weighted stretch and the
reason is an adult is so tight
he's so tight and he's strong at the
same time that the weight of his torso
for example or her torso isn't enough to
help them bend forward mm-hmm so he
can't make any progress it can't make
any progress but if we take them when we
stand them up for example and we have
let them hold a weight in their hand
it's not a giant or not it's important
to separate mobility work from maximal
strength work well we're not we're not
Conan we're not Tarzan which I saw that
movie yesterday it was kick-ass Legend
of Tarzan okay
we're not we're not going out there and
trying to be he-man in super macho what
we're trying to do is remodel connective
tissue and it has its own scheduled 200
210 days for first cycle of adaptation
well right away that means I got to call
my ass down and I need to be patient
here that's that's six to seven months
there is no rush you can't rush right
because this this is hardwired into us
you
can't force it so what the weighted
mobility allows is to gradually take
that strengthen that tightness that we
have and instead of it being a negative
use it as a positive so now that have
that little bit of weight even if it's
let's say it's a Jefferson curl it's
kind of a curling deadlift movement and
they start with a kilo or two just that
little bit of extra weight for the
muscles to have to work against now the
muscles start think of it as flossing
started loosening up they start
fatiguing a little bit which leads to
them relaxing which leads to that
increased range of motion which would
never happen without using the weight
and there are a couple of well the the
extras that comes to mind immediately is
the one you mentioned Jefferson curl and
for people who aren't familiar just cuz
I don't want to assume everyone's heard
the first episode jefferson curl and
feel free to jump in and correct me here
imagine you are standing and you could
certainly start not elevated but let's
just assume you're standing on a step or
a block and you have a barbell in front
of you empty barbell and you would then
tuck your chin and curl down kind of one
vertebra at a time it's basically a
slowly curled back stiff-legged deadlift
yeah yeah where you might target to have
your wrists get past your toes is that
fair description that would and probably
the primary difference between it would
be a stiff leg dead it's going to have
slightly bent knees whereas the
Jefferson curl is going to be completely
straight knees right right so no soft
knees what are some other examples of
very effective weighted stretches
because I I saw tremendous returns and
progress with the Jefferson curl in
pretty in pretty short order and sure I
remember I asked you when should I be
doing Jefferson girls at one point I
didn't see them in some of the workouts
and you said Oh Jefferson curls are to
us Oh Jefferson girls are like breathing
to us okay so I should probably do them
more often then uh what are some other
exercises that you find particularly
effective as weight as weighted stretch
the shoulder extension work so what what
will happen is so few times everything
they do can most of us do conditioning
wise is anterior delt front of the body
they're going to do bench they're going
to do curls they do all these things and
they very rarely put their hands back
behind them an extension very rarely so
they actually create their own shoulder
impingement so that weighted and down we
have think about we have this the pecs
are so strong that the shoulders are
rolled forward they're strong and
they're tight sometimes people
mistakenly think that in order to be
strong they have to be tight that's not
the case order we now today is Friday so
it's opening ceremonies today so real
games are just getting ready to go
gymnasts are going to be first out of
the gate they're going to see ridiculous
strength and power right different
strength power is strength multiplied
ice speed so they're going to see
ridiculous amounts of power then you see
huge muscle mass and they're also going
to see an athlete that's very supple and
mobile and agile so it's very possible
to have both in the the shoulder
extension works it's would that take the
form of dislocates with a little bit of
weight on the bar it probably the
dislocate is going to be from the front
all the way to the back the shoulder
extension work is starting up right
grasping a bar some kind of a bar with a
little bit of weight it might be as
little as a pound
you know our athletes went all the way
up to 20 kilos but you know start start
where they're at and then without
allowing the torso to move at all just
using the shoulders lift the bar up
behind them go ahead goal is to get to
90 degrees if they can start rolling
overhead their grip is too wide so
narrow that grip in a little bit lift
again and keep going goal is to get down
to shoulder width and still being able
to lift to 90 degrees I saw a video on
your Instagram account of a very
peculiar exercise
that I'd love to get your two cents on
and and sometimes I wonder when I see
some of these exercises I'm like did
coach summer just come up with something
for his own entertainment value to see
how many thousands of people who can get
to do this but this one was was
interesting it was someone standing on a
bench like a bench press bench there
what they were holding on to a what
looked like a 45-pound plate could have
just been a bumper plate of some type
underneath the bench so imagine if you
put the 45-pound plate let's just call
it a plate underneath directly
underneath the middle of the bench then
they reach their arms down on either
side of the bench grab this plate
stepped up onto the bench and then went
from bent knees to straight knees trying
to bring their head to their toes
effectively or shins with the plate but
neat like they can't lift the plate up
because it's under the bench what is
this what is this movement and what is
the what are the applications or values
of huh that's that's a weighted pike
and that was part of my elite athletes
daily warmup hmm and then because it's
me of course so some of them the
45-pound plate wasn't enough so I was
kind and generous enough to go over and
help press down on the plate for them
give them some extra range of motion got
it and what would that with a jet would
they do a short number of repetitions
for that particular one yeah they could
go there's a couple of ways we could
program that we could just go a straight
30-second hold so straighten the legs
hold for 30 that was very common for us
we would also do what we call a 10 by 10
so that would be starting from a squat
straighten up little pause back down to
a squat would be 1 do that 10 times and
then the 10 by 10 part comes from on the
tenth one hold that weighted bike for
ten seconds shot it yes no I've done
shorter versions of this for you before
just one or a quick one
I'd kind of like people to stop the
reason we call it mobility instead of
flexibility is because in their head
they think flexibilities being rather
passive that there's there's no strength
involved and I'd like them to start
considering that usable flexibility or
mobility has a strength component to it
that if we have extreme flexibility
that's not supported by strength that's
actually dangerous if the liabilities
actually dangerous yeah it's a liability
I can get my joint way out here and it
can be under load suddenly on the field
of play and I get hurt uncontrolled
range of motion yeah mm-hmm but if
there's strength throughout that range
of motion well now we've increased our
athletic ability we haven't decreased it
this is a question that came out quite a
lot from listeners what is lower body
gymnastic strength training look like
and what let's just great question let's
just say for a 40 year old former
athlete right so it's okay
somebody who's not hobbled right but
maybe there's a recreational athlete
they think they they they think they're
not hobbled right or not hobble yes I
I'll share a story to to show okay
they're more up than they think
they are okay not sure go for it our our
very first seminar that I did working
with adults way back 2007-2008 has some
really athletic people show up really
strong you know by by regular everyday
standards they squatted they deadlift
you know they they were strong and when
I tried to do our entry-level
plyometric work with them so I kind of a
straight leg bouncing that I would do
with my introductory athletes you know
my five year olds they just it destroyed
them
it destroyed them in fact the stronger
they were the faster they went down now
just to dig into that for one second I
apologize but just for the image in my
head we're not talking about like broad
jumps we're talking about sort of a jump
roping movement where they're hopping
like 450 feet down the demo with with
straight legs
yep got it so rather and so we and when
we train we separate jumping movements
where the joint is bending and then
jumping from rebounding movements where
the joints are tight and extended so
they're the Olympics getting ready to
start can I see some crazy stuff when
they're tumbling on the floor
there's no time to jump because it
happened so fast we're using that so the
body has to be strongly extended so that
the connective tissue is what provides
the power there'll be a live we look at
it under we'll get some people who fuss
oh yeah if I look at it under the
thousands of frames a second I can see a
knee flick and like you know what bite
my ass oh no no one can see that as
we're coaching what the athlete is
trying not to tell you both as a coach
and as a former gymnast what we're
trying to do is be as extended as
possible so what happens then is he
taking a dolt and what have they been
doing for conditioning well they've been
doing what they know how to do they're
going in and they're doing leg press and
they're doing leg extension and they're
doing leg curls and they're doing squats
and they're doing deadlifts which are
all primary muscle mass exercises
there's no joint conditioning as far as
a plyometric factor is concerned and
this this is kind of what also leads to
and they're always noticed they're
always exactly on track which everything
is in alignment well that's a separate
discussion but there's no impact so they
get really really strong and this is
what leaves you that kind of weekend
warrior syndrome where they go out now
on the weekend they Monday Wednesday
Friday they conditioned in the gym
they've been working hard their diets
good they're doing their cardio and they
go out to play softball and they go to
run around the base and they have these
strong primary movers but they haven't
done anything for ACL MCL
meniscus their knee goes a little bit I
will I'm in they pop their knee playing
softball so what would you prescribe to
prevent that and whatever we can give
people obviously if they want to dig
into the deep training they need to
look at the more in-depth and
comprehensive courses but what are some
movements that might help yeah they
actually uh some people were really good
on the last podcast we did and through
the comments they put ups also in our
courses you know there are specific knee
exercises because the trainers will tell
you you should always always always make
sure your knees track over your toes
but it's literally impossible to do
anything that includes change of
movement change of direction without
planting the foot and pushing sideways
or in an angle that your knee doesn't
come off track so if all I do is these
primary squats and des I build this huge
strong muscle mass and I haven't done
anything to prepare meniscus you know
where it takes the knees off to the side
and there's you know either direction
and then twisting movements they and
they don't have to be huge loads and you
know we cover all that what we should
put up some samples form remind me Tim
we'll put that up for them but could you
describe one of the movements just for
just for people who want to get an image
in their head what would one of these
exercises look like probably the
simplest one would be a twisting squat
so think of sitting on the ground
cross-legged or we used to call it sit
like an Indian when I was young so
sitting on the ground cross-legged and
stand up out of it without hands what's
going to happen is as they're standing
up and then we're also well we'll ignore
the fact that we're going to also push
on the side of the ankles but just from
that standing up right there they're
working the ACL they're putting pressure
on the outside of that knee and standing
up we had we've never done more than
body weight on these movements we've
never done more than you know for our
lead athletes a single set of ten in
their daily warmup but what it does is
rather than praying and hoping you know
when lighting candles and going to
church and all this stuff that our knee
will never ever ever go off track you
know except that it's going to go off
track and prepare for it prepare for it
so are there any other recommendations
that you would have this is from this is
from a number of runner
in the comments for uh preventing
running injuries besides not running
well well did they were they specific on
the running injuries they were not so
you could you could pick common issues
and how yet it I'll dress them I'll give
I'll give an extreme example so we have
a student Douglas who every year he he
is a maniac for running he loves to do
alter marathons and he lives up in
Montana and he loves to run through the
mountains and he's insane he's insane he
does it's his thing this is now he's
been doing the G B stretch courses which
aren't running specific but their human
body specific if you will right he's
been doing those for a year now and he
said this is the first year that he's
going out and doing his 20 mile runs and
more where he has he's not getting tight
he's not getting the injuries that he
would have gotten before
he says why my body feels good and I was
a little surprised I was like wow you're
you're you're feeling good with that
mileage he might I forget how much he's
doing per week it's something ridiculous
and I he says no and I I feel really
good now that being said right he lives
up in Montana so obviously there's not a
lot of running going on in the winter
because the snow is hip-deep on a
giraffe you know no one's no one's going
out to running that so there was enough
time for him to address deficits prior
to getting back on the trail and running
again so I'm not sure how effective it
could be with someone who already has a
high mileage program and then we add
this and it will be effective but it's
going to be much slower than some that's
offseason yeah let's say their offseason
what would be what would be some
exercises or recommendations for getting
to that point let's see well something
something that they find out is when we
do our front split course a lot of
people get really when we get we
as many as before but we'll get comments
of you know coach what we start them
with calf work ankle mobility we work on
tibialis which is on the front of the
shin and we're working on soleus which
is the lower calf muscle we're working
on the gastroc which is the higher calf
we're working on extension and flexion
in the ankle and we'll get people are
like goddamn it coach I can't
walk today because of these stupid
exercises why why did you put this in so
let me hit let me let me hit pause so I
remember the first time I did this
particular sequence and I'll just give
people some details basically they can
get the idea and it starts off with feet
parallel 60 calf raises and then
stretching and then very quickly like 60
seconds later alright
duck duck stance he pointed out 60 calf
raises and then more stretches and then
he pointed in 60 calf raises and I just
remember this is the first time I did
any stretch workout from you and I was
like holy I am like I'm gonna get
buried by this stretch workout I thought
this is going to be a day off and I'm
only five minutes into it it doesn't it
isn't actually that punishing the entire
time but please please continue input
yeah just want to add some add some
color yeah because what what happens is
people it's important to understand that
our bodies are capable of generating
enormous amounts of power but it was
supposed to be on an as-needed basis not
all day long every day what we are by
nature just due to how our physique is
designed is or endurance animals so your
your calves are designed for endurance
work you're designed they're designed
for you to go out and kill something put
it on your shoulders and then carry it
through the mountain six miles back home
and people don't train their calves like
that anymore so the calf is an endurance
muscle your core is an endurance muscle
your arms are an endurance muscle just
and just why do it for example we used
to take my and we'll come back to calves
we used to have my athletes do very
heavy weighted legless rope climbs and
when I stopped doing that a couple times
a week when I stopped doing that and had
them go on a 7 meter rope triple climb
so up down up down up down jump in the
back of the line their turn comes back
up on a 7 meter up down up down get in
the back of the line come back up again
up down up down so what is that the
seven seven ascents in five minutes all
right because they're just they're just
booking and you know I'm not warm and
fuzzy when we're going to athletes
because this wasn't conditioning
this was warm-up this was a we'd
considered pre strength right at an
elite level if you can't do that as part
of warm-up you're not elite level and
you're not strong enough to do advanced
strength and advanced work on rinks but
what we noticed just as a consequence of
putting on their daily warmup is their
arms exploded hmm which is kind of
contrary for how I was taught coming up
you know if you want to get stronger we
need more load well yes in certain
circumstances but because the bicep and
the arms are endurance muscles because
think about it I go out and I kill
something does it do me any good if I
can only carry something for 30 seconds
right all right I got to be able to
carry this for long durations of time
well calves are the same calves are the
same so a good friend of mine I
mentioned the other podcast was the
Bulgarian Olympic coach I learned a lot
from rumen rumen was the one who found
out that connective tissue like the
Achilles tendon which is what we're
training with those high rep calf raises
thrive they're healthy with high rep
work and if so the converse of that the
flipside of that is if you're not doing
high rep work you're slowly starving
that connective tissue you're slowly
starving it because it's not getting
enough blood flow because it doesn't
have a zone capillary system so it's fed
by exercise and movement now does it
mean you can't do the high-intensity
work you absolutely can but at least
especially the stronger you are at least
once or twice a week you need to feed
these tissues feeding sessions
exactly right tissue feeding sessions
and so if we're looking at these runners
right and we see you're having them in
gorge the calves feeding the connective
tissues and then looking at different
types of bent ankle work before the
hamstrings right right and are there any
other at their level of strength that's
that's probably sufficient later as they
get more advanced so once once we have
healthy joints and we have some
reasonable mobility then we can start
doing plyometric work for because
plyometric work is what it's it's
multiples of body weight on impact
what's running running is going to be a
multiple of body weight during their run
that's why someone who's really weak and
decondition when they go out to run it's
like a session from hell they're just
everything hurts they they're
flat-footed there's no bounce in their
step their lungs burn every everything
hurts compared to someone who's in shape
for it for example way back when right
in high school now we didn't have the
nice floors
that a nice gymnastics compound
competition floors that we have now so
we tumbled when I was coming up on
wrestling mats oh I know they're there
yeah exactly you did rest I know
wrestling that's oh yeah yeah you know
I'm well and so what happens is I was I
was repeatedly exposed to ten to
fourteen when we've measured at Olympic
Training Center when someone does basic
tumbling around up I can spring backflip
they're hitting fourteen times body
weight well not fourteen times for one
single time in training but turn after
turn after turn after turn because it
turns out that how we increase the
strength of connective tissue at really
high levels is very high load very very
short duration microbe fractions of a
second high-intensity microbrews that's
the stress the fastest most effective
way to build connective tissue strength
on a joint that's prepared to do so
so I had a crush on a girl in high
school and she was a big runner
I'd never ran a day in my life except
from chores or something so I
immediately went out she was going to
run in the summer so I jumped to shoot
12 miles a day I went and joined their
their league Track Club didn't notice a
thing within two weeks went out and ran
20 miles didn't notice a thing I
remember talking abusing I don't
understand why people have to train for
this oh I understand this this is
no big deal
and but if someone can handle right that
higher level more advanced plyometric
work where they're hitting 14 times body
weight 10 times body weight are they
going to notice when they're running and
it's maybe two two and a half times body
weight now they're that's that's nothing
that doesn't even exist that you don't
even notice that now we have to build up
to it though what what are the two shift
gears to a different common question
what are the prerequisites for safe back
tuck so back with that backflip now now
let me I can I go to a coach I can let
me rephrase this like what pre foot what
should the checklist be even before
considering it because this is what a
lot of people want to do yeah I I won't
even touch them with it because they'll
be all out there trying to do and
they're all going to die and there are
gonna get mangled and they're gonna land
on their head and they're gonna be mad
at me
mmm goat you told me wrong so yeah for
for the technical stuff anytime that
there's inversion then there's also risk
of injury especially for their running
outside and they're doing it on their
own in their backyard so I really don't
recommend it if if they want to do it
and it's awesome I mean obviously I
spent my life doing this stuff I
recommend that they go to a good
professional instructor don't don't go
to your neighbor and don't pull out
YouTube and say hey cool look at this I
think we can spot each other because
you'll probably spot him well and when
it's his turn to spot you he's going to
it up and he's going to drop you so
let's choose something a little a little
safer not as much fatality risk or
paralysis risk
uh prerequisites for a bar muscle-up
okay or what end or the most common
mistakes in training for muscle ups come
must muscle up you know people will look
at it and they'll go alright now it's
got a pull-up component and it has a dip
component and I'm just going to string
them together and what they're missing
is that there is a transition there's a
transition where they're going from a
pull-up where their elbows are pointing
basically down at the floor on their
pull up to a dip where their elbows are
pointing straight up in between there
that elbow needs to transition through
and in order to make that transition you
have to have shoulder extension mm-hmm
that means I need to be able to let my
elbow go back behind my torso if I don't
have shoulders I feel like shoulder
extension just a totally interrupted be
an it's like if you remember
Seinfeld you ever see Seinfeld and
something bad would happen and Jerry
would go Newman and I feel like for me
that shoulder extension anyway please I
think it I actually think it's for and
it was something that I didn't realize
because this isn't an issue with gymnast
but it took a long time like obliques
also for adults are huge if we wanted to
go down the issues of adults who are
they're not going to have any thoracic
extension they don't have shoulder
extension they their obliques are
unbelievably tight and weak
simultaneously which is kind of sucks
because at least hopefully if you're
tight you're strong but they're not
they're just tight and weak they're para
formas is jacked up and their calves
from all the desk work and sitting on
the chairs are like piano wire yeah I'm
rolling out my foot on a golf ball as we
as we speak standing standing instead of
sitting so coming back to the muscle
that people miss the transition
what would a what would the exercise
progression then look like I know we we
need the shoulder extension so that
would most certainly be a piece
the puzzle but since it's a question
that a number of people suffer
separately well I actually I think you
know and again we got to hammer this
home with them is that they were taught
that these gymnastics elements like this
like a muscle-up are skill training that
their technique training and I'm sorry
but that's a load of horseshit
it's it's not skilled training it's
skill training is a triple backflip
that's a skill training this is a
strength element and in order to do this
strength element correctly the body has
to be able to get into the correct
positions this is why you saw well we'll
say we'll say CrossFit for example for
they were doing the kipping muscle ups
why do a kipping muscle up to avoid the
transition trying to bounce from the
bottom to the top and there's there's
issues of when it's appropriate when
it's now we won't beat that horse to
death think we did last podcast but they
lacked the ability to pull their elbows
behind their body so to my mind if you
can't get in the correct positions why
are you even trying to do the exercise
hmm what would be some good tests for
someone to know if they I guess these
could double as goals in a way but how
could how cus russian dips Russian yes
okay could you describe Russian dips
please sure Russian dip you can need a
little bit of a longer dip handle so get
up in a straight arm support bend down
like a regular dip and then lower back
not we see some people who will lower
under their elbows I don't know who came
up with that stupid variation don't do
it it's worthless it's a waste of your
time lower down and then go on to the
upper arm so that you're basically
laying on the inside of your bicep and
then from there pull back up again to
the bottom of the dip position and press
back up to straight arm got it so this
would be easiest to do on the equivalent
of parallel bars parallel bars would be
good I've seen it on elevated weight
benches I've seen it done on stacked
plyo boxes
now how would you do it on a bench
because I would I have seen the
variation and I'm sure some people out
there if they search Russian dish will
see this on say elevated boxes right
where someone's lowering down basically
onto the forearms but but what you're
saying is you want to lower in such a
way that you end up kind of on the
inside of your bicep is that correct huh
well think of it this way if they're
lowered and this this is actually a
really good illustration what we're
talking about the reason they want to
stop on their forearms is because their
elbows tucked right in at their side
there is no shoulder extension right
right basically they've skipped the
moneymaker they've skipped the part of
the exercise that gives them the benefit
in the first place
rather than going all the way down
getting shoulders back behind them
shoulders back behind their hand and
then as that shoulder starts coming
forward that elbow goes strongly forward
behind the Taurus or backward behind the
torso hmm got it
and if they think they're a real stud
they think they're a real stud instead
of lowering to the bar right do it on
the end of the bar so we our athletes
would go some all by themselves some of
the light spot do it so that the hands
are on the rail but they're lowering and
doing the Russian dip lowering to the
regular position of it but there's no
bar under them to catch it they're just
doing it in the air end point because
isn't that what a muscle-up is yeah I've
seen video of this I what's your take on
foam rolling or other mobility tools or
so-called mobility tools I I like it
especially for someone who is just
getting started
because what will happened over the
years of them being inactive and I
vaguely remember this back when I used
to have hair but like getting tangles in
your hair right so the if the muscles
aren't stretched out on a regular basis
you know stuff just starts getting knots
in it you know just think of it as a
tangle and the foam rolling you know
done well can be a really nice way to
get in there and just break those lumps
out break those knots out what separates
doing
it well from doing it poorly what are
the characteristics well pain actually
so because these these knots you know
that it's unpleasant to loosen them up
and so there's there's got to be some
pressure on there in order to break that
stuff out and you know actually some
some some people will presented that
there's a difference between pursuing
health and pursuing performance that
somehow they're diametrically opposed
and in my approach with all my athletes
over the years I I disagreed with that
vehemently because a healthy athlete is
one that can perform better if he's got
athletes that are injuries that are
niggling in the back of his mind he
can't pay attention at business so the
the healthier we can keep them the more
pain-free we can keep them the better
results were going to get so you know
especially you know Olympics right now
alright are there going to be some
little here and a little there yeah but
overall you know we want we want healthy
healthy athletes with the foam rolling
right if these lot knots and lumps
aren't addressed they're going to get
pulled tighter and if they stay too long
they're going to become adhesions
alright and now that's think of that as
we're starting now to replace muscle
tissue with collagen and obviously
that's that's a horrible bad thing I was
just recently in England doing some
workshops over there and I saw a
gentleman with probably the most severe
Chi photic hunched forward you know like
we we saw a hunch that hook onto them
yep yeah this this guy was night bent 90
degrees forward Wow
and he was walking down the street and I
looked at this gentleman I just like and
then I was like oh my god that poor
bastard and then I saw several other
people like that and I think what's
important for people to realize you know
is because everyone's getting older
we're not were
getting out of this alive rights can
happen to everybody and they need to
start looking around and they need to
see these people who are dealing with
these issues and understanding that the
vast majority of them we're not born
with that issue this happened from a
lifetime of neglect and by neglect I
mean not necessarily know they were
trying to do it but they just didn't
exercise they didn't stretch and before
you know it boom
now I'm screwed and if when it gets to
that point where that gentleman is right
there's no coming back I mean we can go
over crush fractures and how vertebrae
change shape and distension in the neck
and all this stuff but the bottom line
is is if we went way back and started
with just the foam rolling even
something as simple as the foam rolling
and just broke lumps out start getting
some blood flow start loosening things
up quality of life is going to be so
much better later is there any
difference this is a this is a common
comment that I saw tall people let's
just say over six feet tall any changes
or to training in GST for those folks no
no no I know they would like there to be
no but you know we we have got as you
are six and a half feet tall six foot
six and they've got front levers and
press handstands and rope climbs because
what goes with being taller is also
increased diameter of the muscle belly
so yeah it's a bigger frame but it's
it's also a bigger engine now in terms
of acrobatics because those levers are
much longer or if we're actually doing
some hard tumbling in that eotl it's
easier the smaller you are but in terms
of basics and stretching you know just
being a live human being no not so much
hmm and on a related note men or women
different training approaches same
approach once once they get up to an
upper level you know we're not going to
take the girls into the more advanced
ring strength I personally have it I
don't know if there's
who can I haven't done it I will say
that in our gym when Alan was 10 he mice
mice damn whose lol don't Oh Alan was my
last senior lead athlete for the u.s.
national team so ya had him for from 6
to 18 so 12 years of training 16,000
hours Plus that I spent with his
preparation when he was 10 years old he
was capable doing 15 muscle-ups you know
slow no kipping no bouncing and was a
young lady who who beat him and there
were reps in there I didn't count
Chelsea one of our young ladies I was
training at the time doing the physical
prep for our league girls she did 17 if
they were beautiful yeah she was pretty
awesome so for people who are coming in
off the street let's just the sake of
argument say there are 35 former
athletes men and women are the training
approaches the same yes got it okay so
no modifications needed one way or the
other I've been very impressed with some
of the female trainees I've seen on your
Facebook and Instagram who and seen in
person quite frankly at oh and awaken in
Denver who are able to do a slow and
when I say slow I mean almost slow
motion slow muscle up from a dead hang
on the Rings else it up to perfect dip
position maintaining l-sit and back down
it's it's really inspiring and
impressive okay here's one for you and
we only have a couple a couple left and
then will will come to a close but this
is a question from Holly I'm feeling I'm
feeling okay all right coach summer my
boyfriend is also gymnastics coach what
is the most effective way to handle
gymnastics coaches when they get cocky
and condescending
how do people how do people best handle
you thanks in advance there they're
there no solution for that go date a
musician
oh man uh so here's here's a question
and this is a this is a common question
and there there's there's part of me
that gets it and you know part of me has
seen the benefits long enough that I
that don't succumb to this as quickly
however this is a question from mark and
he's talking about some of the
gymnastics training that he's doing the
problem I tend to have is that a lot of
the focus the the drills focus on static
holds at least in the earlier stages is
there a good way to get into gymnastics
that is dynamic and fun more like a
CrossFit variation that is geared toward
entertaining workouts and he says I
don't like CrossFit but I can't deny
their programs have a lot of variety and
stay fresh doing planche is for three
minutes a day every day is really boring
gets demoralizing when progress is
slower even steady now I just wanted to
then somebody gets into idea he's he's
not doing my program uh well so the nono
so even if even if he's not yeah this
this is its I want you to talk about
what people can do to keep morale high
and so he's just talking about its
maintaining not just from a sort of an
optical training standpoint but and from
an emotional perspective sure right well
they probably won't like my answer that
a problem
it probably won't like my answer it
depends on how committed they are to
getting results I look at things that
there are there are two types of
athletes two types of people who do
fitness there there are those with an
immature attitude and there are those
with a mature attitude and it's not
necessarily a chronological division so
an immature attitude is someone who
wants to be entertained they they want
that immediate gratification I want what
I want and I want it right now
the mature attitude is I'm going to do
what I need to do now in order to get
what I want
later and it doesn't seem like it's that
big a difference but it's but it's
actually rather profound it's rather
profound you know if if you and the
higher the goal you're aspiring to the
longer the delay there's going to be in
that gratification now how a beginner
struggles with it because they've not
yet had a taste of success so someone
who's been successful has told them if
you keep nose to the grindstone these
great things will happen you're like huh
yeah sure I know you're full of I
know you're full of this sucks this
is so boring once someone gets that
first taste of success though they got a
little stronger they lost some weight
they built endurance they got more
mobility they get to move to new
exercise oh wow this this worked cool
cool okay awesome well now I'm going to
do it again and it just it just keeps
compiling and you just learn over time
what I would like them to appreciate is
that Olympics are getting ready to go on
right now now one person is there at the
Olympic Games because they spent all
their training being entertained not one
of them not a single one
not just this Olympics ever so if you
want moderate results or you just want
to just kind of you know do a little bit
and be here there then bounce programs
all you want bounce programs all you
want but if you want to actually affect
change on the body you want to remodel
tissue you want to increase your range
of motion
correct mobility deficits you want to
get stronger you want to lose some fat
you want to get your core dialed in
right so you don't have that big gut
hanging over the belly it took time to
break it it's going to take time to fix
it and we're looking at a minimum of six
seven eight months you know to make a
nice solid start well one thing I would
also point out to folks is that there
seems to be and I'd be curious to hear
your thoughts on this coach because
maybe it's just my experience and
maybe it's some type of delusion that
I'm having
but I made a quite a bit of progress
like I mentioned with the J curl and
some of these other weighted movements
and unweighted movements but there are
some that just would not they wouldn't
or didn't feel like they were
progressing at all and then about a
month ago when I was overseas I did a
stretching workout and it seemed like
almost overnight everything had lept
forward like 30% and it was just nothing
nothing nothing nothing and then all of
a sudden it's it was enough it's like I
was stuck in between the gears and I
suddenly got into the next gear and it
was at about the six-month part point
out for some of these movements is that
common that people will just like one
week they'll be like holy yeah it's
completely completely common completely
common and tough tough for a beginner
who feels like God I'm not getting
anywhere I'm not getting anywhere you're
not getting anywhere but it's just it's
just the body adjusting it's just the
body retooling the body things are
progressing but they're progressing at
such a subliminal level that they're not
even aware of it mm-hmm you know
something think of it as there's just
one lot of times it's just one little
thing that's kind of throwing a kink in
the wheel it just needs one little
muscle to get caught up and then
everything else can go forward and it's
just being being patient I think
sometimes it helps it helps for people
to understand that this training working
out Fitness whether it's GST with me
whether it's CrossFit whether it's
tennis it whether it's just hiking in
the mountain it doesn't matter this is a
lifetime deal that biologically your
body is either on or it's off
it's either healthy and thriving growing
or it's dying its decaying there there
is no in-between there is no treading
this isn't a painting that you made you
start it and you can leave it alone and
walk away for six months and come back
and pick up where you are your body is
not that way you've got a couple of days
after a training and then if you aren't
coming back and using your body then as
far as your body's concerned that
strength you've built that mobility
you've built the athleticism you've had
is unnecessary to your survival and it's
going to start breaking it down because
it's expensive to maintain
you know you have to feed all that
muscle you have to feed that metabolism
and your body thinks it's not necessary
and that's where the decay comes in so
you've got to whatever flavor their
fitness that they enjoy this is a
lifetime gig they have to go out and do
something there there is no escape so
there is no escape from Coach Summer
people how many times I have to tell you
and I wanted to wrap up actually I
pulled this up I saved this and Evernote
because I wanted to have it at my
fingertips oh no no not on my fingertips
is like blackmail material but rather
floor you said earlier don't you cross
me coach summer uh the I sent you an
email because I don't want people to
think that I'm just setting up the pins
and knocking them all down every day
just hitting home runs every time I get
up to plate uh I sent an email to you a
few months ago and because I was very
frustrated with something called
particularly particularly frustrated and
I've had multiple points frustration but
particularly frustrated with something
called straddle el extensions which I in
my workout journal I nicknamed I
shortened to frog spaz because that's
what videos of me looked like and I'm
not going to read the whole email
because it's it's it's a decent length
but I'll just read a portion of it which
is the following dealing with the
temporary frustration of not making
progress is an integral part of the path
towards excellence in fact it is
essential and something that every
single elite athlete has had to learn to
deal with if the pursuit of excellent
was easy everyone would do it in fact
this impatience and dealing with
frustration is the primary reason that
most people fail to achieve their goals
and I'm not starting this email where it
started but unreasonable expectations
timewise resulting in unnecessary
frustration due to a perceived feeling
of failure achieving extraordinary is
not a linear process the secret is to
show up do the work go home a
blue-collar work ethic married to an
indomitable will it is literally that
simple nothing interferes nothing can
sway you from your purpose once the
decision is made simply refuse to budge
refuse to compromise so I'm an eloquent
bastard yeah you are an eloquent
eloquent young man sir
and so I think I think that's a good
place to wrap up this round two coaches
there any particular social profiles or
sites that you would like people to
check out okay let's see obviously we
have a Tim Ferris landing page in
massive bodies calm slash Tim Tim has
asked that we're gonna we're going to
update for you guys and put some more
material on there that will in turn take
you to kind of a curriculum page letting
you know you know what are the stages of
preparation what support are available
to you you know as you work your way
through a GB course check out our
Facebook page gymnastic bodies calm a
lot of great stuff on there check out my
personal page on Facebook Christopher
summer good gymnastic stuff occasional
just kind of crazy stuff thrown in there
as well but you guys are used to that
from Tim's page and people people can
also check out your YouTube page which
is youtube.com forward slash gymnastic
bodies for people who are curious about
the Russian dips there's a video the
Russian dips right there
Russian dips in l-sit you can find it if
you go to the videos page it's maybe
four rows down how to use gymnastics
rings standing straddle press the
weighted pike stretch that we talked
about is also on that page lots of good
stuff and lots of exercises that I have
also used already to this up to this
point like the lat flies which are a
really cool exercise exon yeah it lat
flies just to throw the image out there
it's imagine doing a wide grip pull up
to the point that your head is just
below the bar and your arms at the elbow
or bent at 90 degrees and then you're
moving at your torso your chest forward
and backward I mean that's a very
primitive description but maybe maybe
maybe a hanging PEC deck yes exactly
it's like a hanging you're hanging from
pull-up bar but you look like you're
sitting in a PEC deck and then you're
moving your torso back and forth that's
a that's a killer exercise coach I
really appreciate the time as usual
thank you Tim and I'm going to get back
to training this evening and continue my
stretch series and I'm going to go get a
heat pack to work on this wrist that I
have mangled in my own stupidity Paris
is dangerous
you got to keep an eye too much on the
croissants and not enough on proper
training but coach as always thank you
very much and to everybody listening for
show notes as always you can find links
to things that we've mentioned at for
our body duct not a for our body good
for our body also calm if you want to
see my second book but you go to 4-hour
workweek comm forward slash podcast and
until next time thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday the vet provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's 4-hour workweek com all spelled
out and just drop in your email and you
will get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoy it this episode
is brought to you by wealthfront
and this is a very unique sponsor
wealthfront is a massively disruptive in
a good way set it and forget it
investing service led by technologists
from places like Apple and world-famous
investors it has exploded in popularity
in the last two years and they now have
more than two and a half billion dollars
under management in fact some of my very
good friends investors in Silicon Valley
have millions of their own money in
wealth front so the question is why why
is it so popular why is it unique
because you can get services previously
reserved for the ultra wealthy but only
pay pennies on the dollar for them and
this is because they use smarter
software instead of retail locations
bloated sales teams etc and I'll come
back to that in a second I suggest you
check out wealthfront com forward slash
Tim take the risk assessment quiz which
only takes two to five minutes and
they'll show you for free exactly the
portfolio they put you in and if you
just want to take their advice run with
it do it yourself you can do that or as
I would you can set it and forget it
here's why the value of wealth front is
in the automation of habits and
strategies that investors should be
using on a regular basis but normally
aren't great investing is a marathon not
a sprint
and little things that you may or may
not be familiar with like automatic
tax-loss harvesting rebalancing your
portfolio across more than 10 asset
classes and dividend reinvestment add up
to very large amounts of money over
longer periods of time wealthfront as I
mentioned since it's using software
instead of retail locations etc can
offer all of this at low costs that were
previously completely impossible right
off the bat you never pay commissions or
account fees for everything they charge
0.25 percent per year on assets above
the first 15 thousand which is managed
for free if you use my link wealthfront
comm forward slash Tim that is less than
five dollars a month to invest a thirty
thousand dollar account for instance now
normally when I have a sponsor around
the shows because I use them and
recommend them in this case it's a
little different I don't use wealthfront
yet because I'm not allowed to here's
the deal they wanted to sponsor this
podcast but because of SEC regulations
companies that invest your money are not
allowed to use client testimonials so I
couldn't be a user and have them on the
podcast but I've been so impressed by
wealthfront that I've invested a
significant amount of my own money at
least for me in the team and the company
itself so I am an investor and hope to
soon use it as a client now back to the
recommendation as a Tim Ferriss show
listener you'll get fifteen thousand
dollars managed for free if you decide
to open an account but just start with
seeing the portfolio that they would
suggest for you take two minutes fill
out their questionnaire at wealthfront
comm forward slash Tim it's fast it's
free there's no downside that I can
think of this episode is brought to you
by 99designs 99designs
is a great partner for creating and
growing your business it's a one-stop
shop for all of your graphic design
needs whether that's a logo website
business card or anything else I use 99
designs to get book cover prototypes for
the 4-hour body which went on to become
a number one New York Times bestseller I
also use them for banner ads
illustrations and other things with
99designs designers around the world to
compete to create the best design for
you you give feedback and then pick your
favorite you end up happy or you get
your money back it's very simple you can
check out a few of my own designs and
those of yours meaning Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99designs com forward slash
Tim and right now my listeners you guys
will get a free $99 upgrade on
your first design that's 99designs
dot-com forward slash Tim check it out